تحطمت طائره ركاب تابعه لشركه ريزيشن اير
في بحيره فيكتوريا عند اقترابها من الهبوط
في مطار بوكوبا شمال غربيه تنزانيا ولم
تعلن السلطات التنزانيه عن وقوعه اي ضحايا
نتيجه الحادث لكنها اعلنت انقاذ 15 شخصا
من ركاب الطائره وفقا له رساله لمحليه فان
الثلاثه 53 شخصا كانوا على متن الطائره
وذكرت هيئه الاذاعه التنزانيه نسوء
الاحوال الجويه تسببت في هذا التحكم
هذه الصور اذا نتابعوها من بحيره فيكتوريا
قبل قليل وتظهر فيها محاولات الانقاذ التي
مازالت تجرا سقوط هذه الطائره في البحيره
ولم تعلن كما قلنا السلطات ان كانت
الاعداد بالنسبه لمن تم انقاذهم هي كل
الاعداد الذين كانوا على متن الطائره ام
لا سنتابع طبعا خلال تغطياتنا ايه
التطورات بالنسبه للسقوط هذه الطائره